but talking about big thrust into the
limelight air Nicholas Hoult
I always thought the first thing he did
was about a boy but you started even
younger than that don't you
yeah my first kid when I was 500 now see
the gig I'm talking about is casualty
how old are you in casualty I think six
am six years old I think you're at seven
I remember I got to wear a cool leather
jacket well I thought at the time and my
dad let his head on a car jack
and was gonna die well we've got the
plinth not your what the grip so this is
little so very young it's a classic
casualty set up Nicola thought it's very
excited he's very young is too young to
be let loose with a pump for a big tire
yeah but he's playing with it probably
won't end well here he is so he's very
excited pumping away look at him you
know there's this cool leather jacket
he's having a great time
now there's the pitar but see I think
he's getting overexcited
the pressures getting a bit high now
he's that look look too much it's too
much
look look the tire is going to burst
will someone come to help Nicholas
surely his dad will notice oh he has
noticed hang on he's got to go rescue
him
[Applause]
laughs uh pretty direct
[Applause]
I didn't realize it was all my fault
what's inside if I hadn't been doing
that there never wanted me to be a fine
Oh what is the job you did when you were
five a film called intimate relations I
got today I remember the audition for
that cause all I had to do was they
would like to sit under this table and
pretend to eat cake and I was like all
right great I can eat cake all that
[Music]